hi everyone welcome to the financial
stability report press conference we're
joined today by John cunliff Deputy
Deputy Governor for financial stability
Sam Woods Deputy Governor for Prudential
regulation and the governor Andrew
Bailey Andrew will start us off with
opening remarks and then we'll move to
questions
thank you Katie or can I add my welcome
to the press conference for the July
Financial stability report as well
um so before we take questions I'd like
to set out some of the key themes from
the report and also of course the
announcement of Publications that were
releasing today because as you can see
there's a fair as usual at this time of
year there's a fair volume of
information that we've put out
uh so I'd like to write a few start with
a few points I'd like to draw out
um what I'm going to cover is the key
developments so far in the this year in
the Global Financial stability Outlook
the judgments that the FPC has made on
the resilience of the UK banking system
including obviously the results of the
stress test and the decision we've taken
as we always do on the camp cyclical
Capital buffer
moving then on to the lessons we've
learned to date from the recent stress
in the global banking system and then
finishing up on the continued importance
of addressing vulnerabilities in the
non-bank financial world
so on that list let me start on like key
developments so far this year
so we've had a also further rises in
global interest rates
um reflecting
um actual and expected increases in
Central Bank policy rates
um in the UK returning inflation to
Target sustainably will of course
support the fpc's objectives as well as
the NPC's objectives because it will
support uh protecting and enhancing
Financial stability in the UK
now the increase in interest rates of
Market volatility volatility over the
past 18 months has as we've seen created
stress in some parts of the financial
system
and we did of course in March have the
failure of free mid-sized U.S banks and
Credit Suisse
um that caused a rise in risk premium
and volatility around around March
but our judgment is that the impact of
that stress in March on the UK banking
system was limited
and that since then globally Market risk
sentiment has stabilized
and more broadly the UK economy and
financial system have so far been
resilient to interest rate risk
compared to previous periods of high
interest rates households and businesses
are less likely to cut back on spending
and default on loans and I think there
are really two reasons important reasons
to draw out here for this
the first one is the resilience of the
banking system
and that means that the banks have
options to offer support to their
customers a more resilient banking
system has more options in that sense to
support its customers
and the second reason I draw out is that
the FBC and the fca's mortgage Market
measures have limited the buildup of
household indebtedness and increased
borrower resilience
so the point two points I'm drawing out
really are lender resilience and
borrower resilience locals go together
very closely
but it is the case that elements of the
Global Financial system do remain
vulnerable to increased interest rates
and uncertainty surrounding the economic
Outlook and of course tensions
geopolitically speaking
and really as as we point to in the FSR
we point to riskier corporate borrowing
in financial markets such as leverage
lending as an area of vulnerability that
has to be followed closely global
commercial real estate markets which
face a number of short and longer term
headwinds that are pushing down on
prices and making refinancing more
challenging in that world
and I think we do have to bear in mind
that it will take time for the full
impact of higher interest rates to come
through both in the UK and in other
advanced economies and so the FBC will
remain Vigilant to these risks and these
processes taking effect
so let me move on then to the UK banking
sector and its resilience and the stress
test and the ccyb decision
so in the UK we've taken steps over time
of course to ensure that the banking
system is resilient to these risks and
that it maintains robust Capital ratios
and liquidity buffers
and the results of the stress test that
we've published Today Show that the
major UK banks are resilient to a severe
stress scenario
that scenario Incorporated deep
simultaneous recessions with materially
higher unemployment in the UK and Global
economies
increasing Global interest rates
persistently higher Advanced economy
inflation and sharp Falls in asset
prices
now I would particularly note that while
interest rates are higher today and
therefore closer to those which we
published in the scenario that is higher
than when we first outlined the scenario
the scenario is significantly more
severe than today's conditions
and a very important point there is that
it's the combination of higher interest
rates and simultaneous recessions around
the world and in this country and
materially higher unemployment that
makes the stress it's not one thing on
its own that's the key point I would
bring out there
second we're announcing that the FPC has
decided to maintain the UK
counter-cyclical Capital buffer rate at
two percent
this will help to ensure that banks have
sufficient capacity to absorb future
shocks without unduly restricting
Lending
and of course as ever We Stand ready to
vary that ccyp rate in either direction
in line with the evolution of Economic
and financial conditions underlying
vulnerabilities and the overall
environment for risk
now we have observed some tightening of
lending standards from Banks over the
past few quarters
but our judgments we have to make this
judgment every time is that that
reflects appropriate risk management and
line with changes in the outlook for the
economy and the world
it's not a case of restricting lending
primarily to protect Capital positions
and it's that distinction between risk
management and and capital protection
that is critical here
because we will continue to monitor
credit conditions for any signs of
tightening which are not explained
satisfactory By changes in the
macroeconomic Outlook
so the overall risk environment is
challenging and that said we continue to
judge that the UK banking system has the
capacity to support households and
businesses through a period of higher
interest rates
and that the stress test shows that that
would be the case even if economic
conditions were substantially worse than
we currently expect
and move on to the lessons from the
recent Global Financial and global
banking sector stress
the recent stresses that we've seen in
the parts of the global banking system
underscore the importance of maintaining
robust macro potential Regulatory and
supervisory standards
this is this is very much work in
progress in terms of assessing the
recent uh recent events and the FPC will
continue to draw lessons from this
episode
I I think that the episode has
underscored how contagion can spread
across and within jurisdictions even
where smaller institutions are involved
and it highlighted that while an
individual institution may not be
considered systemic in its own right
if a risk is common or perceived to be
common among similar institutions it's
the collective impact that has to be
assessed and can pose a systemic risk
now the pra's regulatory framework here
seeks to ensure that UK banks are
adequately capitalized against the risks
that they're exposed to including
interest rate risk
we will contribute to relevant
International work and are doing so to
consider whether lessons can be learned
from the for the liquidity and capital
Frameworks and in light of the size and
pace of the runs that we saw both in the
US and Switzerland
I think crucially these events also
demonstrated the importance of credible
resolution Frameworks and maintaining
confidence in those Frameworks
over the weekend that Silicon Valley
Banks UK subsidiary failed we conducted
a successful resolution transaction
demonstrating the effective operation of
the UK regime
and in doing so we were able to protect
both depositors and public money
but working with the treasury we're now
seeking to ensure that for small Banks
which do not need to hold additional
resources to meet What's called the mrel
uh they are they are there are
resolution options that ensure
continuity of access for depositors
the stress also demonstrated the
importance of international authorities
commitment to ensuring that the
resolution Frameworks and plans for the
globally systemic banks in line with the
standards set by the Global Financial
stability board remain credible
let me turn to the resilience of
market-based Finance now
recent events as I've just said brought
risks in the global banking system into
sharp Focus
but there remain vulnerabilities in
certain parts of the market-based
financial system
and so there remains an urgent need to
increase resilience in market-based
finance globally
and alongside International work led by
the FSB the UK authorities are also
working to reduce vulnerabilities
domestically where it is effective and
practical
these vulnerabilities could crystallize
in the context of the current interest
rate volatility
the risks were evidence in the Autumn
last year when the stress and liability
driven investment funds required a
temporary and targeted intervention bias
the ability of those funds to absorb
shocks has since been reinforced through
the setting of new standards
in March the FBC recommended that the
pension regulator take action as soon as
possible to mitigate Financial stability
risks
by specifying the minimum levels of
resilience for ldi funds
and since then both the FCA and the
pension regulator have published
detailed guidance on ldi resilience
we welcome this guidance and the steps
taken by pension Regulatory and the FCA
to ensure continued resilience of ldi
funds
we will also develop our approach to
monitoring these risks across
market-based Finance as the financial
system adjusts to higher interest rates
and it's with that in mind that we've
recently launched the systemic
system-wide exploratory scenario
exercise the first of its kind
the aim of this exercise is to improve
understanding of the behaviors of Banks
and non-bank financial institutions in
stressed Financial market conditions
it will explore how these behaviors
might interact to amplify shocks in
financial markets that are core to UK
for natural stability
that's all I was going to say on the
financial stability Outlook but I want
to finish with two personal notes
um the first one is that this is the
last press conference where we'll be
joined by John
John has served on the FPC and as the
bank's Deputy Governor for financial
stability for 10 years nearly and he
will return for 10 years by the time he
uh comes to the end of his term
and before that for I think around two
and a half decades John has been a
public servant of the absolutely highest
caliber
and our gratitude at the banks of John
is only rivaled I think by that of other
institutions in this country for for
which he is tirelessly and steadfastly
served over a distinguished career
if any of you go a present at
International meetings such as the IMF
meetings you'll know the standing in
which Judge John has helped globally
personally I want to give a heartfelt
thanks to John for his contributions our
discussions over the last decade and
before that we will miss John but he
leaves the bank with his ideas and
energy having shaped and inspired a very
grateful Institution
the final note I'm afraid is much sadder
recently we heard the news that our
executive director for resolution
Melanie Beeman tragically passed away
Mel was a world-class Bank supervisor
somebody I worked with for nearly 30
years amongst the best bank supervisors
I've ever met
she was also the life and soul of this
institution
and we missed her greatly thank you
from and if you could limit it to one
question that would be great we'll start
with Ashley
thank you Ashley Armstrong from the Sun
um I just wanted to ask about the the
level of arrears you say that you know
kind of we're going to have a shoot up
but it's not going to be as bad as 2007.
given that in 2007 we had a slightly
different situation you know now we've
got inflation much higher that's eroding
kind of basic income do you think that
there's going to be a greater drift
between the inequality of of kind of
social demographic groups than it was in
2007 because you know it feels like the
poorest are already being hit by
inflation at this level and actually
those that are facing areas will
probably face even more difficulty
actually
okay so so there are some big
differences between now and 2007 as you
say uh 2007 inflation was not rising and
interest rates were going down whereas
at the moment we're seeing the opposite
I think the big difference is uh that
the amount of household debt that's
being carried is much lower now than it
was at the time of the financial crisis
so households aren't really kind of over
levered as they were before and that's
one of the reasons why we think but
households in distress
uh who's uh whose Debt Service ratios
adjusted for inflation will will reach
sort of levels where in the past you've
seen distress that that proportion of
households will be smaller than we saw
in the financial crisis and then
considerably smaller I think it's um
it's clear that inflation hits the
poorest off in society worse and I think
that's that's well known and that's one
of the key reasons why one needs to get
it under control but if we're thinking
about mortgage arrays and the ability of
households to pay then I think the fact
that households are carrying less debt
than they were and that's in part
because of the action that the bank of
England and the financial policy
committee took to put constraints on
mortgage borrowing
um uh that I think will leave us in a
stronger position in terms of distress
I I just absolutely agree with John on
this I've just reinforced that the two
points I made at the beginning yeah we
have we have a you know a set of
borrowers who as John has said
are less exposed and particularly less
exposed to the sort of the at the tail
of the extreme tail
and secondly we also have a banking
system that is more able to support its
customers
a resilient banking system is more able
to support its customers and that's a
critical point as well I mean that's
yeah that's another critical point of
macro Prudential policy the the banks
can support their customers and can
support the economy rather than the
other way around
we've got Ed and then Kalina
hi uh Ed Conway from Sky News how how
can you reconcile the fact that you know
for a lot of people around the country
this feels really tough
with the fact that you have charts now
saying that you know in many dimensions
it's not going to be as bad as in 2008
is that just about the distribution of
the way that you know the pain is being
felt or is is it is it something else
and just a tiny kind of micro second
question do you regret withdrawing the
the mortgage affordability tests in in
2022 would things have been different I
know they've probably improved
um the the nature of those charts right
now but would they have been even more
resilient had you actually left it in
place for a little bit longer
well I'll start off I think
two points on the first part I'll come
on to the test withdrawal points
um I mean the first part of the sense
the first part is the support John just
made which is you know what what macro
Prudential policy and particularly the
mortgage as you just mentioned it I mean
the mortgage policies that we adopted
back you know nearly 10 years ago now
actually
um have done it is that they have
limited
what am I called them yeah the number of
people who are going to face you know
the extreme you know pain and stress of
this uh as a consequence the second
point to make is is a macroeconomic
point that we do have of course much
lower unemployment in this country we
have yeah we have a much stronger labor
markets we're having to deal with that
on another front but on this front of
course it is it is helping a lot in
terms of the stress that households are
seeing on the the withdrawal of the test
I mean the answer is no actually and the
reason is and the reason we would
withdrew the test is that we we had free
tests essentially applying at that time
so there was the LTI flow limit as we
call it which is an FPC measure which is
which is still there and then we had two
affordability tests one was the fpcs and
the other was the FCA it's
and the consequence of all the work that
our staff did in assessing that was that
is that the two of the two affordability
tests and actually also the sum of the
free tests if you like
um was meant that the two the two of we
didn't need two affordability tests one
one was doing the job
um and that's why we would drew the FBC
one because we felt that actually the
combination of the FCA one which has to
be there under under rules and the LTI
float limit test did the job so you know
from the point of view we do obviously
have a Keen Eye on regulatory efficiency
um we felt that did it
you are predicting that uh some
household around a million I think by Q4
2026 are going to see their mortgages
Rise by about 500 pounds
um what impact do you think that's going
to have and do you think they can
actually keep up with those payments
well it's going to have an impact
clearly and I mean I have to be you know
I mean you know put my monetary policy
hat on for a moment of course that is
past the transmission of monetary policy
um no question about that and I just
come back to this point with my number
of times here I think what would what
we're seeking to do here with when we
this is why the bank of England has
responsibility for both monetary policy
and financial stability
excuse me that we are trying to balance
um
having the transmission of monetary
policy with the two things I would
emphasize one is the resilience of the
banking system
um and two is is the ability to support
customers and therefore manage the
manage the consequences of this
but but there will still be consequences
from increased interest rates I'm afraid
because that's that's from a monetary
policy perspective why we have to do it
Laura and then jumper
thank you Lauren Eden from the flagship
times um just a quick question about the
efforts that are ongoing to try to get
encourage Banks to increase their
savings rates and to reduce their
mortgage rates do you have any concerns
from our financial stability perspective
about those efforts like is it a
dangerous game to get into telling Banks
to offer higher savings rates telling
Banks to control their mortgage rate
increases in this environment thank you
well I I don't understand about what's
coming let me start off with I think one
big message from this morning from what
we've released this morning
which is that the resilience of the
banking system is not a constraint
on banks managing their net interest
margins and therefore managing the rates
they they pay to save as on the rates
they charge on mortgages and that's
important there is not a because it
wasn't always the case in the past as
you know
um it's very important that the
financial stability is not a constraint
in that sense so Banks can take the
decisions that they that they need to
take
um on that front without having to in a
sense restrict for financial stability
reasons and I think that's that's a very
important thing now in terms of saving
rates you know I'll make three points I
think all of which I've made before but
they're important important to make one
is it is the case and we do draw this
point out that we've seen more
pass-through in fixed deposits than we
have in site deposits
I I'm not saying that you know Banks can
um take no have no regard for site
deposits but there is a reason for that
which is that particularly from the
point of view of liquidity management
for banks uh fixed term deposits have a
have a value in that sense we come back
to the point about exposure to runs
actually at that point so there is a
there is a value to that now it's not
surprising that we've therefore seen
customers swish
deposits from site deposits to fixed
deposits and that's happening and that's
not not surprising at all
so I think that's that's an important
point to bear in mind a second important
point to bear in mind is that there is
what I might call a more structural
rebalancing of rates going on as we move
away from the zero interest rates
obviously when we went to effectively
zero interest rates
if you go back to before the financial
crisis so back into the sort of time
when we had rates you know more in the
realm that we have them today
it was pretty typical for
um the rates the average rate that Banks
paid on savings to be just below uh our
official rates
when our official rate went down to
nearly zero that relationship reversed
um and what we're now seeing is that it
re-establishing the old the old sort of
order if you like and I don't think
that's terrible a surprising thing to
see
so those two points I think you know are
important as part of the sort of
understanding the transmission but I'll
finish the third point
it is important that obviously rates get
passed through I think it is also
important that we have competition in
the banking system which encourages
Banks to compete and and compete on
saving rates and again just to
re-emphasize a more resilient banking
system will be able to compete I mean
again they're not they're not they
haven't got one arm tied behind their
back by the need to you know to Achieve
Financial stability they can compete on
that basis and that's a good thing
which is we have also explored that in
the stress test so in the stress test
we've done two things one is
that we've made the proportion of
non-interest bearing household deposits
dropped by 15 percentage points people
migrating more into term uh that's more
than the banks put into us and more than
we've experienced so far and the other
thing we've done to illustrate Andrew's
point is we've uh required uh the level
of pass-through to be such in in the
stress test that the spread between site
household interest bearing deposits and
bank rate goes back down to the throttle
level it was at in the 2000s which is
about 220 basis points versus more like
the 285 that we've seen recently so
we've made sure Andrew is saying that
the system is kind of capitalized and
tested against a higher level of posture
I think the structure of banks
liabilities
um uh deposit accounts will change and
they changed after the financial crisis
I think a period of very low interest
rates meant the number of the proportion
of Bank liabilities accounted for by
non-interest uh bearing deposit accounts
groom
um and the proportion of remunerated
fixed term uh deposits shrank and what
you're seeing now and I think that's
what you would expect to see as interest
rates go up is those proportions moving
and we're getting a greater move into uh
into more fixed term remunerated
deposits and from a financial stability
point of view redressing that balance
that's a good thing because as Andrew
said that's more stable funding for the
banks and you would expect them to want
to pay more for that and actually to
bring bring us back closer to the
pre-financial crisis levels they also
get the benefits and our liquidity
regime which um Sam operates uh if they
have more stable funding
jump up
good morning
um I just wanted to ask please about the
debt servicing ratio that so that the
proportion of uh of the post-tax income
being being paid in mortgages expected
to rise to eight percent by mid-2026.
um and that's going to be lower than it
was in the in the 2007 crisis does that
comparison in in one sense all those
kind of comparisons uh give the MPC in
in a sense a green light for for
interest rate Rises but also uh what is
that rate going to be when it's just as
a proportion of people who have
mortgages uh is it I've seen it said
that it's more like 25 of their income
is going to be spent on on debt
servicing uh and how does that compare
to the to the um to the crisis levels
I'm not sure if you've done that in in
the report
[Music]
I'm not going to use the green light
analogy
um because obviously we're not giving
any messages about what will happen to
interest rates here but what I would say
is this
that obviously monetary policy and
financial ability are sort of closely
you know closely interact here
so that of course you know the MPC has
to have regard for uh the stability of
the of the financial system and the
stability of the environment when it
thinks about its actions and that's
actually written into the into the
operating sort of rules and we do that
and so again a more stable environment
uh is one in which monetary policy can
do its job I mean it's easier for margin
policy to do its job when it's operating
against the backdrop of a stable
Financial system
uh and I just emphasize I think that's a
very important Point
um
I don't have a number yeah we'll come
back just as a proportion of that yeah
thanks uh Philadelphia Bloomberg um John
I think a year ago you suggested that
interest rates are about five percent
would start to cause problems for
corporates and and also put more you
know sort of dangerous dangerously high
levels of households in debt distress it
seems in this report today that five
percent isn't
um isn't causing undue distress among
corporates all households so what is the
level at which we'll start to see
problems I just wonder if you could also
explain what's happening on the ldi
front I understand that there was
further recapitalizations
um with their billions more and what
what's been happening on their front
so both just on I think what I said is
there was a range uh I think it was
between 200 and uh 500 basis points so
quite a big range so that would take us
to an interest rate uh considerably
higher where we are now uh one of the
things that we've seen though I think
over the last uh over the last year is
actually
um uh through
um basically the support that banks are
offering through the ability to extend
term through the ability to uh to change
mortgage terms I think that there are
we'll move on to interest only I think
which is a part of the Chancellor's
package that actually there are more
options there for people to soften that
but the number we give in the in this
report and there's been some changes
because we were talking also about um
not just mortgage payments for cost of
living trying to take account of both
the impact of inflation and higher
mortgage repayments and we've we've t
the inflation numbers to add more
elements of inflation in which has made
it sort of uh made the inflation
pressure go up a bit but the number
we're giving now is about 300 basis
points uh for that mortgage rates to uh
interest rates to increase before you
reached those uh those debt levels which
are the levels we've just talked about
uh uh we had in the financial crisis so
we've seen that shall we say highly
indebted number move from 1.6 percent of
households uh to about two percent uh
but it would need to move uh up to about
3.5 to get back to where we were the
financial crisis and the number we give
there is about 300 basis points uh to
get there yeah yeah but we gave a range
last time
um yeah and you came to the bottom end
of the range and I've just given you
something close to the top end of the
range
we've essentially sort of set what we
think is a sensible buffer level for
them to hold uh as as a sort of you know
as a buffer against stress
what that meant was that when interest
rates went up there was no disorderly
needs to a sense you know try to call
down assets to recapitalize the ldi
funds
I've been like that there was a movement
of assets but that happened in a very
sort of uh yeah an orderly fashion which
is what we want the other points I'd
make about that movement is of course
that it's actually the case that when
interest rates rise the underlying
position of Pension funds actually
strengthens according to the accounting
the net asset value of Pension funds uh
strengthened so it's not a question
that's what I call the underlying
solvency of Pension funds it was the
problem of the need to to do this sudden
and quite disorderly transfer of funds
which which couldn't happen in the time
available so with the buffer in place
that problem is is mitigated
well there will be some there'll be some
rebuilding of a buffer but it wasn't it
wasn't that large actually so we didn't
so uh immediately after the ldi crisis
um until we'd kind of worked out a more
longer term solution we asked the funds
to be holding about 300 basis points
um to be able to accommodate a 300 basis
point shift uh in uh in
yields
um and they put that in place they put
it in place immediately after the ldi
incident we've since formalized that and
we in the last in the last um uh FPC
round we set out requirements for them
to hold a standing buffer of about 200
250 basis points and then enough to deal
with Market moves and that pretty much
is where they they kind of were at the
time with the extra resilience that we
put in immediately after the crisis some
of that buffer has been used up as
yields of of move but as Andrew says
what the buffer is trying to do is to
give them time to actually recapitalize
to get contributions from the sponsor
Pension funds and the sponsor Pension
funds can do that because their
liabilities are going sort of down in
value faster or by more than their
assets are going down in value so this
is really a question of how do you deal
with an acute liquidity crisis second
point of course is we've seen the
movement up in yields
but I think during the ldi crisis
yields went up by about 150 basis points
in three days which was a an
unprecedented
sort of speed and that was being driven
by by other events whereas now we're
seeing yields go up as the market kind
of works out or re-estimates where bank
rate will need to go to um to bring the
inflation back to Target so that's a
more gradual adjustment process so the
combination of the fact that this is
happening over a more gradual period And
the fact they have the buffer to absorb
it means that they've been able to uh to
absorb those increases in guilt yields
without the financial stability stress
that we saw back in September
bill
thank you uh Bill Stromberg from Reuters
um just come back to the report I I
think you referred to how the stress
that we saw in the banking set parts of
the banking sector recently uh
underscored the importance of
international authorities and their
commitment to making sure that the
resolution framework remains remains
credible can I can I just ask did the
way that Credit Suisse
um the way that creditors was taken over
did that affect the credibility of of
those uh of the Global Financial
resolution rules on an international
level and secondly seeing as you have
put your monetary policy hat on a couple
of times already today and you talked
about the uh the labor market what was
your takeaway from yesterday's jobs
report was it more of the signs of
accelerating pay growth or or were you
more taken with the signs of perhaps
some weakness or some looseness coming
into the labor market
yeah I want to start with um Credit
Suisse
um
obviously Credit Suisse there was a
resolution on Credit Suisse let's let's
let's be clear on that
um it wasn't a resolution that followed
the sort of the The Playbook exactly
um
but of course I mean I should say that
um you know there is always some
flexibility within the playbook for to
when you have to have that because we
can't we can't prescribe every every
situation that's going to occur
so I don't think that's the issue uh and
I'm not going to get into the question
of sort of you know what happened what
didn't happen around the route that was
chosen
what I think is important and I've said
this before is that there was a there
were comments made that you know this
there were Doubt cast on the global
globally significant Bank resolution
plans more broadly
by virtue of not using the Playbook and
deciding that the Playbook couldn't be
used
now that's a very serious issue because
if that is the eight two things points
I'll make it one we can't ignore that we
can't live with a world where there's
ambiguity that's just not of course it
accepts all the risk is much too great
secondly we have to go to the bottom of
the question well you know is this or is
this not accurate in terms of the
description of um
of of the resolution plans which are
because have come out of the work done
in the Global Financial stability board
and then implemented by all of us as
National authorities
and that work is going on you know the
the resolution Committee of the Global
Financial stability board led by Marty
Greenberg is is very focused on that I
will give because I think I've said this
before in public I'll give you my own
you know starting point on this I'm
afraid I do remain to be convinced that
that assertion
that there was you know that there's
cast doubt on these plans more generally
is the case I'm afraid I'm I'm I'm not
convinced by that assertion
but I am very convinced that that we
have to obviously kick its tires and
test it thoroughly to decide whether
these plans are still fit for purpose or
whether we need to go back to them and
change things you just cannot this this
is far too important to sweep that under
the carpet so that's the yeah might be
of the position did you want to just
just to say I mean some of that work at
the international level Financial
stability board uh looking at resolution
in the light of Credit Suisse and in the
light of the three U.S banks um that
need to be resolved
um uh at the last meeting of the the fsp
plenary and there was a press notice it
just gave some of the conclusions
initial conclusions of that which was
there was a viable incredible resolution
option so I think a better way to think
about it is that the Swiss authorities
had
a number of choices they happen to have
a private sector buyer although he came
with other things as well and they chose
one route rather than the other one but
the fact they chose one route doesn't
mean the other route wasn't a viable
incredible alternative and I think it's
some of the kind of heat and noise
surrounding that as Andrew said
um uh perception may have grown that
there wasn't a credible resolution
alternative I think the work and the
work the fsp is showing is that though
there are lessons to learn from Credit
Suisse as there are from Silicon Valley
Etc and the regime you know always needs
to take account of uh of actual
instances
um that the credible resolution Options
under the international framework are
there and can be used and there won't
always be a private sector buyer so you
know
online markets um obviously it's not a
managed policy press conference this
morning but yeah good try
um the Manchester policy committee
obviously hasn't uh yeah we'll be
starting around next week actually
um so what I would say I'm just saying I
think a number of commentators have said
this about yesterday's data is that
there were you know there are two parts
to it you can see that I mean um I'll
repeat what I said at the mansion house
not for the first time on
on Monday evening which is the current
level of pay increases are not
consistent with the inflation targets I
mean that's I'm afraid of you know a
fact of life and we have to deal with
that
on the other side when he looks and I
think you were referring to this when
you look at the sort of the quantities
side of yesterday's report I think there
are some interesting you know pieces of
evidence they're not actually that newer
evidence I mean it's a continuation in
some cases if you look at the vacancy to
unemployment ratio ratio for instance
um of some signs of the of the labor
market cooling
um and we do pick that I picked this up
and we picked this up when we yeah we go
around the country actually do you know
you are hearing more stories so what I
will say is I mean that's that's the
that's the job of the MPC we're going to
have to sort of put all this information
together again and see what we make of
it
Tim
Tim Wallace at the Daily Telegraph
um can you expand a bit more on the
plight of um small landlords are they
facing a bit of a Wipeout given the
sharp rise in interest rates and can you
talk about the implications of this for
house prices and for uh rents as well
um and also are there any um are we
still seeing um any help coming through
for households from the pandemic savings
that they built up are they um helping
people through the shocks they're facing
at the moment
yes on the um on the smaller landlords
Point
um we're we're not very concerned
um by that from a financial stability
point of view
we do include in today's Publications an
assessment of what the we think the
average increase in a monthly payment
for a buy to let landlord would be
likely to be
um over the course of the next couple of
years and we put an estimate there of
275 pounds a month now it is true
um that if everything else was held
static and landlords had no ability to
adjust any of their other incomings and
outgoings
that that would push are considerably
higher portion of vital that mortgages
below a key threshold that we use in
supervision which is an interest rate
coverage ratio of 125 and it would
actually increase that number from about
three percent to just over 40 percent
um but of course in in the real world
other things are not held fixed and
here we have actually seen over the last
year around a five percent increase in
rents and that is a product of the
pressures that landlords are facing at
least in part
um partly from of course change in
financing conditions but also other
pressures that they have so um uh we
expect the situation to continue to
evolve in that way we've included a
number also of the net sales coming out
of that part of the market in terms of
properties which is a actually
relatively small number of 100 000 in
the context the overall
um housing market
um only other point I would make is that
we we do of course stress test all that
in our stress test and we do stress buy
to let mortgages we think they have a
higher impairment rate in our stress
tests than others but overall if you
look at mortgages it actually goes back
to the earlier question as well
um we think that the impairment rate
that we'd see in mortgages in our stress
test which is a much worse version of
the world than the one we are actually
in at the moment would only be 0.9
percent that's actually down from 1.6
last time we did that and that's because
the the quality of assets has improved
in the meantime not least because house
prices have gone up and therefore the
portion of
um these mortgages which has a higher QV
is pretty low so a finish on one one
point to illustrate that which is
that the um the stock of vitalet
mortgage is 94 of them I have an LTV of
less than 75 percent
so the general point on that which
um two general points I mean one there's
a lot of other things going on in the pi
to let Market
um there have been taxation changes to
new environmental standards their
changes uh to uh the structure of
tenancies and how Tendencies how you can
end tenancies okay so there's a lot a
lot of other things apart from interest
rates but the more General point is
um yeah we've come out of a period of
very low interest rates uh and the
period the the percentage the proportion
of uh smaller small private sector
landlords grew during that period and
now we're in a period of um higher
interest rates where there are other
returns uh in in other parts of other
sorts of Investments and you would
expect that there will be some
rebalancing as we move and it's it's the
same point as the rebalancing of deposit
accounts you know one would expect those
flows from a financial stability point
of view question is does that happen in
a in a way that can be accommodated
what's the impact on the banking sector
and as as Sam said the the net outflow
when you look at more the larger
landlords coming in uh to the market is
is not particularly large at the moment
but I think we should expect as we go
through this period that people will
change their investment preferences
because the relative value of different
Investments you know changes
I think that rebalancing was already
happening just consistent with John's
points about other factors before
interest rates started to rise I should
say
got it
sorry
well I think no I think you're right I
mean I think that the um the build up of
um of saving and particularly the build
of unexpected saving Beyond uh what
you'd expect during the pandemic does
provide some buffer in that sense yeah
obviously by the way of course the real
value of that saving has come down but
but it still it does provide some buffer
here
yeah
Dave and then Cohen thank you David
Robinson market news
following the footsteps of the New York
fed do you place any weight on the idea
of Double R star there is a rate policy
rate at which you create Financial
instability
I noticed that Catherine Mann referred
to it recently
and if you do attach weight to that are
we above it or below it
well I'll start off I mean I think
you'd have to ask the question why what
is the underlying reason you know why
you you take rates to whatever level it
is
um I would caution against merely
running a simulation and a model than
saying what if we put rates to you know
pick your number
um what would happen because you'd have
to look at the underlying reason I mean
this is the point where things come from
a number of answers to number of
questions yeah we've got yeah we've got
a higher interest rate today but in a
very different context to the one we see
in the stress test so you have to take
that in terms of the what breaks it you
really do have to take that into uh into
consideration so you've got to specify
the I think the sort of the scenario
very carefully to do that type of
analysis because you'll get different
answers for different uh different
scenarios yeah and maybe just a
so General Point stepping back so the
economy will go through different Cycles
over time there will be an interest rate
cycle this one has been fast
by historical standards but in terms of
the amplitude of the cycle
actually not not so very different
um the job of financial stability is to
make sure that when that happens
the financial sector has the resilience
to deal with it or first of all to make
sure the financial sector doesn't cause
it which is what happened in 2008 but
even if it doesn't cause it that it has
the resilience to deal with that so
monetary policy has the freedom to
operate and that in a way is what the
stress test is all about so it posits
unemployment at 8.5 5 recession Etc and
says can the banking system deal with
that so that monetary policy does have
the freedom to operate to do what is
necessary to bring inflation about the
Target and I think that's a more helpful
way of looking at it than saying in a
model somewhere is there a rate that
that breaks this do people lose money
when you know the economic circumstances
change they do and actually it's a
function of markets in the system that
that should be part of it but the
question is can the financial system
well adjust to that change without
falling over in the way that we saw
happen uh 15 years ago that's in the in
the stress test and the Judgment that's
in this episode
I mean I just
emphasize this point that I think
historically
slightly at the risk of what I said on
Monday evening about we always
understand life backwards
um
unemployment is one of the best guides
to impairment in the in in in in the
sort of the in the banking system
um you know that that's been the case in
the past obviously we've had very big
spikes in unemployment in the past
during the sessions
um and and you yeah that's why you see a
very different situation today but then
again as John just said a stress test in
which we've tested with a level of
unemployment that's just over double
what we've got today and and the system
is you know is resilient to that
so thank you so yeah Governor Billy said
March so Boe took a decision that HSBC
bought UK Services
what lessons can you install from this
exact whole event whole processes for
future financial crisis and do you think
the Banking Act 2009 is effective on
through this exact experience
well I
I think there's a number of lessons
um I take from that weekend but we were
all close to involved in it so we'll
have our perspectives but let me draw
out
three things about that weekend in the
context of Silicon Valley UK
one is that in the UK system we have
for quite a long time now actually
required as part of what we call pillar
two of the capital system
slightly the intricacies of Basel Basel
globally as pillar one and then pillar
two is things that you you know you
choose to implement nationally
we've implemented what we call interest
rate risk in the banking book uh Capital
requirements that's important because
that covers whatever risk banks are
taking
through as we saw with svb globally yeah
this this capacity to have an interest
rate mismatch in the banking book and so
we've we've always for a long time
required Banks to hold Capital against
that risk and as a stress test yeah used
to in a sense calibrate that that
interest rate risk that's the first
thing I mean I think that is important
and I think
the second thing is
um and
I'm going to be quite careful what I say
here because it has been covered
um
it it is the case that Silicon Valley
Bank UK subsidiarized about a year well
last year actually I mean it was
actually about a year ago wasn't it so
much I think and that's because it it
was approaching the sort of the policy
that we already had we already have in
place
um as to at what points we think it
makes sense for back there for back to
subsidiarize in the context of how many
um effectively insured or fscs eligible
deposits it's holding
now I just want to be careful here
because things have been written about
this of course we're doing the Lessons
Learned I I just want to say it doesn't
mean that we're about to you know about
to enact some radical change to the
subsidialization policy I think I think
it was a particular benefit to us in
this case because frankly if we hadn't
had it we couldn't have done a
resolution
the FDIC would have been doing it
um but so of course we because we always
review these things but I just want to
be very careful that we're not you know
cooking up some radical change we're
just looking at it and saying how did it
work I think the third thing I take take
from it and you know here I'll be you
know quite open about it I think the
first two things I've set out meant that
we had a resolvable entity we had
something that we could resolve
um yeah I think the thing was in the UK
and looked to me certainly to be
basically solvent
um and resolvable and that's you've got
to have that really to get into the yeah
Enterprises if you're talking here I'm
talking about resolution in terms of
transfer and sale to another party
another thing then you have to have is a
party that wants to cut wants it
um and we had it in this case you can't
always rely on that I've done quite a
few resolutions in my time they don't
always work like that but put those
three things together and it came
together but what we're doing is saying
well okay so that's that was that was no
good helpful but we have to look very
carefully then and say you know what do
we learn from that in terms of you know
messages we can make and that's what
we're doing
well maybe I could just add just two two
weave points one is I think the events
that have taken place in the U.S banking
system are a useful reminder of the way
that contagion can happen within a
banking system we had very limited
contagion uh into our own system only
really through wholesale funding costs
and Bank share prices but it's a
reminder of that and something to be
aware of and secondly just to go back to
a point that Andrew had mentioned
earlier
um we feel we had a very successful
resolution of Silicon Valley Bank UK
um uh and yeah from from a standing
start on a Friday morning to a Sunday
afternoon we had three different options
that we could have taken
um and that's a good place to be much
better than where we were say 10 years
ago so that reinforces the confidence
that I have in that part of our toolkit
um but as Andrew was saying you need to
learn from these things and there is a
question do we want to broaden our
toolkit to have some more options for
depositive continuity
um in smaller firms and that's something
we're working on
hi uh Chris Doyle from cityam
um
I guess I was wondering
that um
generally it seems that risks emerge in
quite unexpected places in quite
concentrated ways and I take all the
points that this scenario is testing you
know
high unemployment inflation Global
downturn what can it tell us about risks
that emerge
um in very specific markets say in
Commodities and where the the changes
that take place take place very quickly
and how can Banks prepare for that
well also I'm sure Jonathan wants to
come in um two things I'll say in this
one in constructing the scenario for the
bank stress test yeah we do look more
broadly than just the sort of core UK
markets so you'll see from looking at it
for instance that we've obviously once
again had to think quite carefully for
instance about uh about risks in China
and Hong Kong because obviously our
major banks are you know are very active
in those markets much more so than other
you know often other other sort of major
banking uh sectors elsewhere
so that's an example of something we
always you know look at carefully
because we we have the exposures in that
respect and so you have to look at them
very carefully we also look very
carefully at something at areas like for
instance leverage lending because it's
another we highlighted again in this
report and having quite a few previous
ones it's an area where we do think
there is more risk um commercial real
estate would be another one so those
those things we do second thing I'd say
is I just move on to the
um
the num well the the market-based
finance tests the the exercise we're
launching
the thing is that your question is
really very relevant to this actually
which is
um how you know I've said before I think
one of the big challenges with the
non-bank world is that it's a very big
landscape
quite diverse as you said
and also we've found by experience that
sometimes the problems can emerge and
you know quite opaque and slightly
obscure parts of that that world
and so the tech the challenge that we
have to set ourselves are both you know
pay around globally is how can we sort
of in a sense get our arms around that
um efficiently
and the exercise we're launching is very
much for
as I see it as a learning experience to
say you know how can we take this
forward now and actually you know put
this into practice
um because it is
yeah it is a challenge I mean you
mentioned commodity markets you could
you can I mean in a sense ldi which I've
said before it wasn't the major part of
the ldi industry that was that where the
particular problem arose it was in the
uh so-called pooled funds which only
probably about 15 of the ldi markets so
if these are these are substantial
challenges and ones that you know we
know we've got to sort of get our arms
around and so the exercises again in the
market-based finance world is a is a big
step forward in how we can actually do
that effectively
you know I look like just um that's for
cash that we saw in March 20 is actually
quite illustrative of of that
um we know that there is what I would
call fragility in in Market liquidity
under stress so we've seen jumps to a
liquidity over the last few years in a
number of instances
um and some of that is to do with
um the way in which the system interacts
as Andrew said market-based Finance much
more diverse
um and I don't think the FPC has a
regular Horizon scanning exercise where
it looks all that we're trying to uh
we're trying to improve that we have the
the system-wide exploratory test which
is essentially a test of how the market
works together uh coming up but we know
that there are some areas where if you
like liquidity stress gets Amplified and
transmitted across the system money
market funds open-ended funds impact of
Margin Call in stress some of the hedge
funds strategies these things have been
well identified over the last few years
it's an international issue because
these markets are are kind of uh
International you can't really solve
much of it domestically but there is
work going on in the uh in the fsp
they've just brought out something on uh
on open-ended funds we've got
improvements on money market funds uh
where in the UK they will be putting out
our proposals later on there will be
proposals coming I hope on margin so
there are things we can do but we have
to really have to act internationally
try and reduce that liquidity fragility
because we've seen when the system works
together you can just amplify liquidity
stress that would problems go but will
we always know everything that is
happening in those markets globally I
think that's going to be very difficult
I mean just I'm starting what John said
if you go back to March one of the
things particularly in the ux you saw
was a flow out of banks into money
market funds now that emphasizes the
fact that money market funds are you
know an important part of this we've got
yeah we've got FSB proposals out there
but they've got to be put into effect
at one point which is when we talk about
the stress test we tend to focus mainly
on the real economy variables but we
also have a very significant Trader risk
stress the banks take a 30 billion pound
loss and in amongst that the banks are
required to default five of their
uncoateralized counterparties in two of
their largest collateralized
counterparties so I think that gets to
the sort of risks that you were asking
about
at
hi it's sorry just another quick one um
so you correct me if I'm wrong on this
but looking at the stress test it does
look like some of the Ring fence banks
that did particularly well I just wonder
whether is there a lesson from that
given you know the talk about the
Edinburgh forms given you know people
are looking at this right now is it is
it a warning of the resilience of the
current system and a warning about
messing with that system
I think by far the most striking thing
about the stress test is in fact that
the capital drawdown in other words the
capital hit is really quite a lot
smaller than the last time we ran a test
of similar severity so it's a three and
a half uh point to order versus 5.2 last
time that we did this and within that
you're quite right to observe that the
ring fence Banks even have a have a
lower drawdown
um that that is good news
um that is a product of changes we're
talking about earlier in terms of asset
quality it's also things like um some of
the Legacy books from actually was still
with us from before the financial crisis
having got smaller and rolling off since
then and some changes in lending
standards since I think that is good
news but what you do see though of
course
um in the ring fence Bank results is
sort of what you'd expect that the the
effect of the scenario on the ring fence
Banks is a bit more homogeneous than the
effect on the banks overall and you
would expect
um but that is obviously something we
have to have an idea it is of course
very important that we are stressing
those Banks to things that could really
happen because there is more of a
possibility Naturally by Design if you
like that the wing fence Banks results
could be more similar Through Time
all right we'll do fill and then Bell
and that's it
thanks um yeah for launcher again uh
just on uninsured deposits I think you
you sort of touched on uh the fact that
you know resolution regimes are being
looked at
um there's been talk about returning the
fscs into a recapitalization fund has
been talking about talk about
pre-funding the fscs as part of these
reforms I just wonder where we are on
that and current thinking
yeah and look I'm not going to say
preachers where that's all going to end
up you're right we're looking quite
broadly at this I don't by the way think
the answer is just to raise the limit
um you know the 85 000 I mean there may
be a case for doing something 85 fast
and I'm not going to Prejudice that for
a moment but the answer is not to raise
the 85 000 as case and
in a way that was one of the lessons I
think or one of the messages from uh
Silicon Valley UK
um which was the actually what it had
was some very lumpy corporate deposits
which were the working capital of
companies I mean they were you know
there was it was the lifeblood of these
companies and you know we were very
aware of that from the messages we got
over the weekend
um so I don't think just saying or if we
put it up from 85 to you know some other
number that's larger than 85 isn't it
that doesn't really do this do it so we
are looking as we said you know more
broadly at the resolution toolkit if you
like
um as Sam was saying earlier
um to say you know how can we address
that question because I think
you know the point that did come across
that we kind of this is to be clear was
that in the corporate deposit world
um you know these are these accounts are
of course you know so much the lifeblood
of how these companies operate
um so I think it does you know does make
it clear that we have to we have to look
at that afresh and say what can we do
but I think the answer if it probably
lies in the resolution toolkit rather
than the fscs limit world
um the treasury is
spoken to and reached agreements with
banks about ways to minimize forbearance
in the mortgage Market also other ways
to help people who are struggling
perhaps with their mortgage costs on the
other hand the bank of England is using
you know interest rates to execute
monetary policy how close are we to a
point where the two institutions are
almost working at log at loggerheads and
is this something that you discussed
with the treasury around the time that
they were talking to the banks about
what they could do to make mortgage
costs more bearable for people well
we're not we're not loggerheads at all
actually
um I think you know one of the things
that the monetary policy committee has
to do is understand that obviously the
transmission mechanism of monetary
policy is an important part of monetary
policy setting and so understanding that
and understanding how it's changing and
of course in the mortgage area it's
changed a lot since we lost it was 20
years really since we last had a rate
rise cycle
so the shift to a predominantly fixed
rate market and then the question of you
know how the process of resetting rates
actually works is an important
consideration for the for the MPC but
we're not at loggerheads and I'll just
come back to a point I made I think very
early on on that just a financial
stability point of view
I mean it is I think you know very
helpful to have a banking system that
can support its customers
um you know I don't think any of us want
to go back to a world where the rate of
repossessions of houses if you're back
to the early 90s for instance the
recession of the early 90s
um the rate of repossessions that was
was in there and obviously the effect
that has on people and on families you
know we don't want to go back to that
world and I think we're in a much better
place with a banking system that can
support its customers in reasons so and
also loggerheads I think it's a matter
of understanding the impact of these
measures
you
have your conversions